on se fait dire à sa cause de vous
autres qu'on est confiné benon cherche
pas à cause de nous autres ça cause de
virus
la comédienne louise latraverse et
sensible aux histoires d'aînés qui se
font effective et on m'a raconté que
deux les gens sont sont refusés dans les
épiceries c'est de la discrimination il
devrait pas parler des vieux existe pour
les traités justement comme tout le
monde
daniel lacroix actuaires à la retraite
s'est fait demander son âge par une
employée à la porte de sa pharmacie ce
monde à l'envers à me demander quel âge
avez vous j'ai dit plus que 70 des
belles heures à midi normalement je
devrais pas vous autorisés à rentrer
mais je vais faire une exception dans
votre corps alors non seulement on
discrimine mais on l'a vous qui on passe
par dessus de ça finalement ça qu aucun
sens c'est pas de me faire dire que je
suis bien qu'ils me qui m'insultent
c'était d'être prise dans un bloc qui ne
m'appartient pas le nombre de plaintes
auprès de la fadoq est assez préoccupant
pour que l'organisme le signal au
cabinet de la ministre responsable des
aînés marguerite blais en guey à maison
c'est l'homme vous devez être moi j'ai
trouvé cette déclaration lors
condescendante méprisante
alors que commence la septième semaine
de confinement il y a une certaine
confusion autour du caractère
obligatoire des consignes et sur les
différents milieux de vie des aînés
on leur dit nos côtés prenez la sorte
est resté pas enfermer quand vous pouvez
évidemment c'est pas tous les milieux de
vie qu'il permet et de l'autre côté on
leur dit si vous avez 70 en plus vous
êtes plus à risque n'ont pas de
développer la maladie mais bien d'avoir
des complications par la suite quand on
regarde les statistiques des gens qui
sont décédés
certains avaient des comorbidités mais
pas tous donc des personnes âgées que
leur seul facteur de risque ce mélange
aucune directive empêche les 70 ans et
plus de sortir mais le ministère de la
santé
le recommande d'éviter les endroits
publics pour
propre sécurité toutefois le confinement
est obligatoire pour les personnes
hébergées en ch et celle des et celles
qui habitent en résidence privée pour
aînés
peu importe leur âge on vous aime donc
on veut vous protéger mais je pense que
quand on aime bien quelqu'un on doit
d'abord le laisser libre le choix de
louise latraverse est claire je sors à
peine sûrement faire une marche mon
trottoir et j'aurais chez moi parce que
j'ai juste pas envie d'attraper ce virus
moi je trouve que personne au dessus de
70 ans à une certaine élégance
et puis ça nous différencie ici à
nourrice despatie radio canada montréal